if you are involved in this protest we
will actively look to identify you and
follow up with financial sanctions and
criminal charges
canada's parliament is extending prime
minister trudeau's emergency powers used
to crack down on convoy supporters but
conservatives say it's being used to
target law-abiding citizens like a mom
who donated a small sum of money to the
movement that is unconscionable joining
us now fox nation host tommy larry on a
tommy tuesday tommy how is this
tolerated in a democracy
well quite frankly i think trudeau just
declared his country to be a
dictatorship not a democracy it's
something that you shouldn't see in the
united states you shouldn't see in
canada something that you'd more likely
see in places like venezuela cuba or
china but i want to talk about our
government because the fact that our
leaders have not stood up and said
anything about this about our neighbors
to the north and what they're doing to
their citizens and the robbing of their
civil rights and liberties and quite
frankly their voice the fact that our
leaders have said nothing about it is
what truly concerns me and i believe
it's because they relish the idea of
doing something very similar in the
united states should a convoy come and i
believe that they also want to have that
on the table to weaponize against their
political opponents but i also have to
say that those freedom truckers and
those that support them have more
intestinal fortitude than most americans
that i know but there are so many
americans that support what they are
doing and if we've learned anything in
the last couple of years it's how
essential truck drivers farmers and
ranchers are and how unessential actors
are politicians and those who claim to
be so important not the case we need our
essential workers and we stand behind
them we certainly do and i want to talk
to you about crime that's happening
across the country in particular the
story that's unfolding in new york city
where there's this career criminal
arrested 46 times 46 prior arrests he
gets caught mugging someone
and then he is charged with grand
larceny d.a alvin bragg's downgrades a
sentence he said he was going to do this
now it's happening uh what do you make
of this situation and uh the fact that
these criminals are still getting off
pretty easily
that's what happens when you have states
that essentially have one party rule
like new york and california and
elsewhere and it's also what happens
when you adopt these felon coddling
policies under the guise of criminal
justice reform this isn't criminal
justice reform and if you want criminal
justice reform you should put career
criminals and thugs behind bars and keep
them there and protect the law-abiding
and decent citizens of your cities and
of your states and what needs to be
asked is why these liberal das why these
democrats are so beholden to the thugs
the felons and the criminals and not
beholden to the citizens that they are
supposed to protect and defend that is
the question that needs to be asked i'm
not sure we'll get an answer but it begs
the question and more people need to ask
it finally tommy the washington post
editorial board supports a federal
no-fly list for passengers who simply
don't obey mask mandates on flights what
does a statement like that tell you
about the mindset of the media itself
and the people who ultimately work in
the media
well i also think it tells you that much
of the mainstream media wants to keep up
the coveted fear and covet hysteria and
of course the covet control there's been
so much division in our country over the
last couple of years over covet and the
continuing hysteria and the face mass
mandates and the vaccine mandates but it
also tells you if you contrast that to
the earlier story about crime in cities
you've got so many of these liberals who
want to treat the masculists as thugs
and degenerates but want to treat actual
thugs and degenerates as social justice
warriors and martyrs for a cause that
just shows you what a messed up time we
live in and unfortunately the mainstream
media is complicit with that on
airplanes we know that those cloth face
masks are essentially decorative face
coverings at this point so it's time to
unmask it's time to breathe freely and
we shouldn't be treated like criminals
for doing so much to the dismay of
liberals who want to keep up that covet
hysteria tommy i prefer when you call
them a face diaper that makes my
tuesdays usually so please regale us
always always a face diaper and i will
make sure i say it for you next week
thank you tommy that's our tommy we
appreciate it
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now